vous présente notre piscine avec
l'espace à la avouez le
nous sommes loin de la visite
traditionnelle d'un appartement pour
étudiants on a du vélo on à tapis de
course derrière vous piscine salle de
sport gratuite et un logements flambants
neufs entre 30 et 40 mètres carrés là on
est sur un t2 ça peut être aussi un
studio avec ils ont tous effectivement
une terrasse une cuisine équipée séjour
si l'offre faite par la directrice de
cette résidence pour seniors
un loyer à zéro euro en contrepartie
près de deux heures par jour avec un
objectif être aux côtés des personnes
âgées
ça peut être sur un dépannage
informatique par exemple un petit
problème internet mais aussi une partie
une parent parmi une partie de jeux jeux
de société jeux de cartes etc
c'est vraiment du lien on veut vraiment
la création de liens l'intégration de ce
jeune auprès de nos résidents vraiment
passé effectivement des vrais moments de
vie tous ensemble trois fois par semaine
par exemple
l'étudiant devra un dîner avec eux
car ici il est très attendu je trouve ça
vraiment bien
déjà il peut continuer ses études pour
pour venir ici
il a quand même pas de loyer à payer il
sera avec nous puis moi je vois une
jeunesse c'est positif parce que c'est
toujours bien d'avoir de la jeunesse
autour de nous ça nous maintient disons
plus jeune depuis l'annnonce de ce
logement presque gratuit la direction a
reçu plusieurs candidatures si on est
sur des personnes qui sont locales qui
les wings oui oui tout à fait les trois
candidatures cdc des jeunes entre
guillemets de nevers on recherche
surtout une personne voilà qu'un savoir
être très développés qui aime le contact
humain qui aime les personnes âgées les
seniors parce qu'il va vraiment être au
contact des seniors et puis de l'équipe
de tout un tas de personnes qui aurait
aucun cas une fibre qui soit voilà
qu'ils soient communicants qu'elle
communiquait partagé dans des résidences
comme celle ci ou chez les particuliers
le phénomène se développe cette année
la france compte plusieurs milliers de
cohabitation intergénérationnelle